This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. My boy Maslow's favorite color is red. My boy Carver's favorite color is blue. Carver is okay with the color red, but Maslow hates blue. They're twins, and for those who don't know them well, the color they wear is how people tell them apart. These colors were not chosen for them, it just happened. It is fundamental to who they are. When you're a kid, your favorite color is one of maybe five of the most important aspects of your personality. Over the course of our lives, the fervor for a specific favorite color tends to die down. But over the course of human history, the search for the brightest splash of color
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我儿子马斯洛最喜欢的颜色是红色。我儿子卡弗最喜欢的颜色是蓝色。卡弗对红色没意见，但马斯洛讨厌蓝色。他们是双胞胎，对于那些不太了解他们的人来说，他们穿的颜色就是人们区分他们的方式。这些颜色并非为他们而选，只是碰巧如此。这对于他们的个性而言是根本性的。当你还是个孩子时，你最喜欢的颜色是你性格中最重要的五个方面之一。随着我们年龄的增长，对特定颜色的狂热往往会减退。但在人类历史上，对最明亮色彩的追求
has been a defining feature of our species. Cassius and Claire is fascinated by color, how it's made, what it means, and how it defines us. She wrote a beautiful book called The Secret Lives of Color that I love so much that I invited her in to talk with me and she's riveting. So this episode is just that. My conversation with Cassia Sinclair, all about the secret lives of color. So Cassia, how did you begin becoming obsessed with colors and what made you want to write a whole book about the lives of color? Yes, I'm lucky that I came from quite a creative family.
一直是我们物种的一个显著特征。卡西亚·圣克莱尔对色彩着迷，包括它是如何制造的、它意味着什么，以及它如何定义我们。她写了一本名为《色彩的秘密生活》的精美书籍，我非常喜欢，所以我邀请她来和我谈谈，她非常引人入胜。所以这一集就是关于这个的。我和卡西亚·圣克莱尔的对话，全是关于色彩的秘密生活。那么卡西亚，你是如何开始沉迷于色彩的，又是什么让你想写一本关于色彩生活的书呢？是的，我很幸运，我来自一个非常有创造力的家庭。
My mother was a florist and I have very vivid memories of kind of messing around in her flower shop when I was little and I would be given kind of like the offcuts to make little bouquets from. So that was, I think, the beginning of my love of colour. But I became interested in it academically at university because I was studying 18th century women's history and more specifically what women wore to mask-grade balls during the 18th century. And one of the things that I loved about studying this very
我母亲是一名花艺师，我小时候在她的花店里玩耍，记忆非常深刻，她会给我一些边角料让我做小花束。所以我想，这就是我热爱色彩的开端。但在大学里，我开始从学术角度对它产生兴趣，因为我当时在研究18世纪的女性史，更具体地说是18世纪女性在化装舞会上穿什么。我喜欢研究这个非常
niche topic is the fact that I got to read so many journals and letters about what people were planning to wear or had worn at parties and you know it was sort of filled with gossip and something that really struck me time and again was the fact that friends were using colour terms in these letters and diaries and accounts that were completely unfamiliar to me and that I would have to go and do an awful lot of research to try and recreate what that color might look like. And sometimes it was just impossible for me. I simply wouldn't ever be able to find out exactly
小众话题的原因之一是，我读到了许多关于人们计划在派对上穿什么或已经穿了什么的日记和信件，你知道，里面充满了八卦。有一件事一次又一次地让我感到震惊，那就是朋友们在这些信件、日记和记录中使用的颜色术语我完全不熟悉，我必须去做大量的研究，试图重现那种颜色可能是什么样子。有时这对我来说根本不可能。我简直无法查明
what that color looked like. And the fact that the color vocabulary had just shifted, I was in London, I was in the same city where these people were writing about. And it really wasn't that long ago historically. And yet, the colour terminology had changed really almost completely. The colours that were faster and more than were not colours that I even recognised. And that just blew my mind and sort of continued to be of interest to me, and I would always be fascinated by it.
那种颜色到底是什么样子。事实上，颜色词汇已经发生了变化，我当时在伦敦，就在这些人写作的同一个城市。从历史上看，这其实并没有过去多久。然而，颜色术语几乎完全改变了。那些更快、更多的颜色甚至是我都认不出来的。这让我大开眼界，并持续引起我的兴趣，我一直对它着迷。
And I mean, in your book, you talk a lot about the relationship between language and color and one of the most interesting things to me was how different languages divide up the color spectrum differently. Yes absolutely so if you think about a color wheel or you know if you think about a way of representing all the colors we could possibly see it wouldn't be in you know a straight a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r decide this is red and this is blue and this is purple. That can really change. And it can change on an individual basis and also on a linguistic basis.
我的意思是，在你的书中，你谈到了语言和颜色之间的关系，对我来说最有趣的事情之一是不同的语言如何以不同的方式划分色谱。是的，绝对是这样。所以如果你想到色轮，或者如果你想到一种代表我们可能看到的所有颜色的方式，它不会是那种直接的……决定这是红色，这是蓝色，这是紫色。这真的会改变。它可以在个人基础上改变，也可以在语言基础上改变。
So various languages have divided up the spectrum differently into more or fewer groups, but also in different ways. So for example, Russian speakers have a word for darker blue and a word for lighter blue, for example, and some languages only divide the color spectrum into kind of three or four groups. Right. I always struck by this in your book that in the section on pink, that there's a word
所以各种语言将光谱划分成了更多或更少的组，而且方式也不同。例如，俄语使用者有一个词表示深蓝色，有一个词表示浅蓝色，而有些语言只将色谱分为三或四组。没错。我在你的书中总是对这一点印象深刻，在关于粉色的章节里，有一个词
for pink, and there's no word for light yellow or light green. It's just, it's so strange that it has its own nomenclature. Yeah, it's a real sort of cultural oddity and particularly, you know, pink now plays such an outsized role in our culture both because it's associated with women and girls, but you know, for good and ill. But also we just we just seem to really love it in Western culture. It comes up a lot and and you're right, far more than you would think of, say, a pale green or a pale blue. Yeah. I mean, there's a sense that these colors exist, kind of as concepts, but your book, The Secret Lives of Color, is really about color in the material world, about the pigments themselves. And so I kind of want to go through a few of those pigments to sort of tease out
表示粉色，却没有表示浅黄色或浅绿色的词。这太奇怪了，它竟然有自己的命名法。是的，这确实是一种文化上的怪事，特别是，你知道，粉色现在在我们的文化中扮演着如此重要的角色，既因为它与女性和女孩联系在一起，你知道，有好有坏。但我们也似乎在西方文化中真的很喜欢它。它经常出现，你是对的，比你想象的浅绿色或浅蓝色要多得多。是的。我的意思是，人们有一种感觉，这些颜色作为概念存在，但你的书《色彩的秘密生活》实际上是关于物质世界中的颜色，关于颜料本身。所以我有点想通过其中的几种颜料来梳理出
these types of stories that we get. And I was thinking that we could just start with red because it seems to be the most universally loved color through history. Why is that? Yeah, it's a really interesting one. So one of the questions that I get asked without fail every time I do a talk about color is whether colors make humans have a real physical response. And quite often this idea is slightly junk science, like pink makes you calm or whatever.
我们得到的这些故事。我想我们可以从红色开始，因为它似乎是历史上最普遍受喜爱的颜色。为什么会这样？是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题。所以，每当我做关于色彩的演讲时，我必然会被问到的一个问题是，颜色是否会让人产生真正的生理反应。通常这种想法有点伪科学，比如粉色让你平静之类的。
And it's very hard to really pin down valid scientific data on this. But red is the colour where the most tests have been done and the most tests have come back with fairly compelling results a'r gweith are wearing red have won on average more than they should have done statistically. Wow. And there was another similar study done on the Olympics as well, you know, the Athens Olympic Games on combat sports and it, and again, you had similar results, which it does just seem incredible, but also makes you think that if you're ever to play a sport,
要真正确定这方面的有效科学数据是非常困难的。但红色是测试最多的颜色，而且大多数测试得出的结果相当令人信服。穿红色的人在统计学上平均赢的次数比他们应该赢的要多。哇。在奥运会上也有类似的关于格斗运动的研究，在雅典奥运会上，结果也类似，这看起来确实令人难以置信，但也让你觉得如果你要参加体育运动，
you should definitely make sure that you're the team where I'm red. And red is also one of the oldest colors. Can you talk about how people made red in the ancient world? Sure. So, one of the oldest pigments, all this red pigments that we know about is hematite, which essentially you can kind of think of like rust. It's iron oxide, you find it in okas, reddishokas, and the sort of chemical compounds from which it's made
你绝对应该确保你是穿红色的那支队伍。红色也是最古老的颜色之一。你能谈谈古代人是如何制造红色的吗？当然。所以，我们所知的最古老的颜料之一是赤铁矿，你基本上可以把它看作是铁锈。它是氧化铁，你在赭石、红赭石中可以找到它，它所由之构成的化学化合物
are really common in the earth's crust. You get kind of red-earth, red-tinted earths, geographically in really widespread areas. So it's not surprising in a way that it's cropped up in a lot of different archaeological contexts all over the world in China and as America, North Africa, Europe, it's cropped up again and again and again. It's so universal that it was sort of dubbed by a 1980s
在地壳中非常普遍。你在地理上非常广泛的区域都能找到红土、红色的泥土。所以它出现在世界各地许多不同的考古背景中并不奇怪，在中国、美洲、北非、欧洲，它一次又一次地出现。它是如此普遍，以至于被20世纪80年代的一位
anthropologist as one of the sort of the two consistent markers of kind of human evolution, along with toolmaking, that was the other one. So wearing hematite red and toolmaking are the things that make humans human. Yes. That's amazing. But hematite sort of falls out of fashion
人类学家称为人类进化的两个一致标志之一，另一个是工具制造。所以佩戴赤铁矿红和工具制造是使人类成为人类的事情。是的。太神奇了。但赤铁矿有点过时了，
because we find brighter versions of red. So one of the reasons why I love color as a subject, you know, I'm just so fascinated by it, is because humans have always gone to the most extreme and extraordinary lengths to get their hands on brighter and more interesting shades. And that's really evident when you talk about red. So, you know, yes, they have this really widely available red earth that they can sort of dig up from almost anywhere in the world, but that is not enough, it's not bright enough. And so somewhere along the line, someone discovers that if you crush up
因为我们发现了更明亮的红色版本。所以我喜欢色彩作为研究对象的原因之一，你知道，我对此非常着迷，是因为人类为了获得更明亮、更有趣的色调，总是会采取最极端和非凡的手段。当你谈到红色时，这一点非常明显。所以，是的，他们有这种非常容易获得的红土，他们几乎可以从世界任何地方挖掘出来，但这还不够，它不够亮。所以不知从什么时候起，有人发现如果你压碎
a type of scale insect that can be found in Europe called the Kermis scale insect, a'r ymdyn ni'n ei'r ysgwyrddio'r cymryd yng Nghymru'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydau'r cymrydio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith these scale insects, what you usually die, this very vibrant red. And so eventually, the name of the cloth, which is Scarlet, Woolen cloth, became kind of synonymous with the red that it was so often died. And that's kind of how the name Scarlet and the color red came together. It was actually sort of borrowed from a very fine Woolen cloth. Oh, wow.
一种在欧洲可以找到的介壳虫，叫做胭脂虫，……这些介壳虫，你通常会染出这种非常鲜艳的红色。所以最终，这种布料的名字，也就是“猩红色”（Scarlet），羊毛布料，变得与它经常染成的红色同义了。这就是“猩红色”这个名字和红色这个颜色结合在一起的方式。它实际上是从一种非常好的羊毛布料中借用来的。哦，哇。
That's amazing. There's another red. Can you help me pronounce this? This is like Coach Chenille. How do you say? Yeah, Coach Chenille. Coach Chenille red. Can you help me pronounce this? Is it like coachanille? How do you say it? Yeah, coachanille. Coachanille. Yeah, so it's actually, yeah, and it's
太神奇了。还有另一种红色。你能帮我读一下这个吗？这就像是胭脂红（Cochineal）。你怎么说？是的，胭脂红。胭脂红。你能帮我读一下这个吗？是像“cochanille”吗？你怎么说？是的，胭脂红。胭脂红。是的，所以它实际上是，是的，而且它
very similar actually to Scarlett, because it's also made with a scale insect. But this one, rather than being European, is very common in South and Central America. And was used very widely by Aztecs and Incas in their culture and again it was associated with rulers and power but it was also a part of their taxation system in a way. So when there were sort of vassal states, the vassal states would be expected to give their rulers certain numbers of sacks of cosonial dye or the dried bugs, sort of every month or two months, depending on how wealthy
实际上和猩红色非常相似，因为它也是用介壳虫制成的。但这种虫子，而不是欧洲的，在南美和中美洲非常普遍。并且被阿兹特克人和印加人在他们的文化中广泛使用，它再次与统治者和权力联系在一起，但它在某种程度上也是他们税收制度的一部分。所以当有某种附庸国时，附庸国会被要求每个月或两个月给他们的统治者一定数量的胭脂红染料袋或干虫子，这取决于这个附庸国有多富有。
this vassal state was. So it was really sort of highly valued and really embedded in the culture. How did this colour interact with colonization and trade around the world? So colors and colorants, you know, have been one of those things that people go and take over other countries and exploit other areas of the world for it. You know, they're very often natural resources that people are desperate to get their hands on and that they can make an awful lot of money from back home. And so, you know, Coshineal was one of the products that the Spanish were desperate to get their hands on
所以它确实被高度重视，并真正植根于文化中。这种颜色是如何与世界各地的殖民和贸易相互作用的？所以颜色和着色剂，你知道，一直是人们为了它而去接管其他国家并剥削世界其他地区的东西。你知道，它们通常是人们拼命想要得到，并且可以在国内赚取大量金钱的自然资源。所以，你知道，胭脂红是西班牙人拼命想要得到的产品之一，
in order to get this red colorant back to Europe where it was actually many times stronger than the kermis dye that had been originally used to color scarlet cloth. Coshineal is much stronger. And so it's much more cost effective and great sums of money could be made and were made in the export and use of this dye.
为了把这种红色着色剂带回欧洲，它实际上比最初用于给猩红色布料染色的克尔梅斯（kermis）染料强很多倍。胭脂红强得多。所以它更具成本效益，在出口和使用这种染料的过程中可以赚取巨额财富，而且确实赚到了。
And it took like 70,000 bucks to get a pound of cochineal, right? Yeah, I mean, with all these dyes that are made out of animals or animal products, you know, that it's really the poor creature that's involved in the making of the color really does get completely hammered, you know, very often it takes an awful lot of them to produce not very much dye or not very much colourant and often you find, you know, them being driven to the brink of extinction just because people are so keen to get their hands on the color. And do we still use insects like these to make pigments today? in Quebec extinction just because people are so keen to get their hands on the colour.
需要7万只虫子才能得到一磅胭脂红，对吧？是的，我的意思是，所有这些用动物或动物产品制成的染料，你知道，真正参与制造颜色的可怜生物确实受到了彻底的打击，你知道，通常需要大量的它们才能生产出很少的染料或很少的着色剂，而且你经常发现，它们仅仅因为人们如此渴望得到这种颜色而被推向灭绝的边缘。我们今天还在使用这样的昆虫来制造颜料吗？
And do we still use insects like these to make pigments today? Yes, so there is a slightly grim side to this particular colour in that it's a natural red colour and also because it's really highly pigmented, It's been used in kind of food and also cosmetics. So if you were to look at your strawberry yogurt or something like that, you might see that it's been colored with comic acid or you might see it down as the colorant E120. And that is in fact, cochineal bugs.
我们今天还在使用这样的昆虫来制造颜料吗？是的，这种特定的颜色有一个稍微阴暗的一面，因为它是一种天然的红色，而且因为它色素含量很高，它被用于食品和化妆品中。所以如果你看你的草莓酸奶之类的东西，你可能会看到它是用胭脂红酸着色的，或者你可能会看到它被标记为着色剂E120。而那实际上就是胭脂虫。
Whoa, okay. So if you see E120 that you're eating bugs. Yes, but if you think about it, all the colorants that are used in food, I mean, you know, maybe we're all different, but you know, if you replace E120 with another colorant, that the likelihood is that that colorant might well be an extract from like a coltar sludge, which is where a lot of other colorants come from. So, you know, I don't know, coltar or or... You could eat cold, you could eat bugs. Yeah, exactly. So, as you mentioned, the color for a pigment, it can be pretty rare in nature and it tends
哇，好吧。所以如果你看到E120，你就是在吃虫子。是的，但如果你仔细想想，食品中使用的所有着色剂，我的意思是，你知道，也许我们都不同，但你知道，如果你用另一种着色剂代替E120，很有可能那种着色剂很可能是从煤焦油污泥中提取的，这是许多其他着色剂的来源。所以，你知道，我不知道，煤焦油或者……你可以吃煤焦油，也可以吃虫子。是的，完全正确。所以，正如你提到的，颜料的颜色在自然界中可能相当罕见，而且往往
to require the wholesale slaughter of an entire species to make it happen, which sort of brings me to Tyrion Purple. Can you talk about Tyrion Purple? Yeah, so this is one of my favorite stories from this book, because many people have this automatic association between royalty and purple, and it's one of those kind of cultural links that maybe you don't think about too much, but actually the link goes really far back and it is based on this amazing purple die
需要屠杀整个物种才能实现，这让我想到了泰尔紫（Tyrian Purple）。你能谈谈泰尔紫吗？是的，这是我这本书中最喜欢的故事之一，因为许多人对皇室和紫色有一种自动的联想，这是那种你可能不会想太多的文化联系之一，但实际上这种联系非常久远，它是基于这种神奇的紫色染料，
called Turion Purple. Again, it's an animal-based colourant and it comes from two varieties of shellfish that are native to the Mediterranean. And if you were to go and find one of these shellfish, they're quite spiny, so you'd have to be careful when you picked it up. And if you were to crack it open, you would see that there's kind of a pale gland that runs across the back of the shellfish. And this gland contains a single drop of liquid that smells a little bit like garlic. Apparently it's really unpleasant smelling like garlic breath and this liquid is phenomenal when it's exposed to the light, if you were to sort of rub it on a piece of cloth and expose that piece of cloth to the light, it would immediately change colour.
叫做泰尔紫。同样，它是一种基于动物的着色剂，来自两种原产于地中海的贝类。如果你去寻找这些贝类中的一种，它们相当多刺，所以你捡起它时必须小心。如果你把它敲开，你会看到有一条苍白的腺体横跨贝类的背部。这个腺体含有一滴闻起来有点像大蒜的液体。显然它闻起来非常难闻，像大蒜味，这种液体在暴露在光线下时非常惊人，如果你把它涂在布上，让那块布暴露在光线下，它会立即变色。
It would turn yellow and then green and then blue and then finally purple. The colour that it produces is very distinctive and very vibrant and this was the dye beloved by the ancient world and became again because it was very expensive, really associated with power and royalty. So again, you get lots of legislation dictating who can and can't wear it. There's a kind of a famous story about the emperor Nero who turned up to a recital and saw a woman in the audience wearing a terrain purple gown and she wasn't, you know, of the right class or status to wear it. And so he had her taken from the room and whipped and had all her lands confiscated because he saw
它会变成黄色，然后绿色，然后蓝色，最后紫色。它产生的颜色非常独特且充满活力，这是古代世界所钟爱的染料，并且再次因为非常昂贵，真正与权力和皇室联系在一起。所以同样，你有很多法律规定谁能穿谁不能穿。有一个关于尼禄皇帝的著名故事，他去参加一场独奏会，看到观众席上的一位女士穿着一件泰尔紫色的礼服，她并没有（你知道）合适的阶级或地位来穿它。所以他让人把她从房间里带走，鞭打她，并没收了她所有的土地，因为他认为
this as a real way of usurping his own power because she was taking the power bestowed by this color. It was so potent a symbol symbol which is kind of amazing. Yeah. But again like the poor scale bugs the the four shellfish you know went through went through horrors because of humans desire for this purple so you know it takes about 250,000 of these shellfish to produce just an ounce of dye and so people were hunting these shellfish a'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r fforddd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd or ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd o'r ffordd die in the classical era. The discarded shells have almost become kind of hills outside the town, very often downwind of the town, all the diworks which were generally associated downwind, so that the citizens who ended up wearing the terryon purple gowns wouldn't be bothered by the smell of the manufacture. Wow. And so when did purple kind of lose its association? I mean, it's always been
这是一种真正篡夺他权力的行为，因为她正在夺取这种颜色所赋予的权力。它是一个如此强有力的象征，这真是太神奇了。是的。但同样，像那些可怜的介壳虫一样，那些可怜的贝类，你知道，因为人类对这种紫色的渴望而经历了恐怖，所以，你知道，大约需要25万只这样的贝类才能生产出一盎司的染料，所以人们在古典时代一直在猎杀这些贝类。丢弃的贝壳几乎变成了镇外的小山，通常在镇的下风处，所有的染坊通常都设在下风处，这样最终穿上泰尔紫色礼服的市民就不会被制造过程的气味所困扰。哇。那么紫色是什么时候失去这种联系的呢？我的意思是，它一直
associated with royalty, but when did it become acceptable for a common folk to wear it without getting whipped? Well, to re-imperial, both because the shellfish, you know, became incredibly rare, but also because of political turmoil around the Mediterranean, which kind of really disrupted the manufacture of the dye. To re-imperial itself, largely disappeared from view. Purple kind of goes into a little bit of a decline until the mid-19th century, when an entirely new purple dye was discovered completely by accident and this sort of led to a revival. And what's that what's that I call? So the the new purple dye that
与皇室联系在一起，但它是什么时候变得让普通百姓可以穿而不被鞭打的呢？嗯，随着帝国衰落，既因为贝类变得极其稀有，也因为地中海周围的政治动荡，这在很大程度上破坏了染料的制造。帝国本身在很大程度上消失了。紫色在某种程度上进入了一点衰退，直到19世纪中期，一种全新的紫色染料被完全偶然地发现，这导致了复兴。那叫什么？所以，19世纪中期发现的
was discovered in the mid 19th century is called MOVE and it was discovered by an 18-year-old scientist who was at home on holiday and using his vacation time to try and find a synthetic version of Quinnine, which was a cure for malaria. The time, malaria, agues, were really common in Europe. And it was thought that being able to produce a synthetic Quinnine would be a huge money maker for anyone who could discover it.
新紫色染料被称为“苯胺紫”（Mauve），它是由一位18岁的科学家发现的，他当时正在家度假，利用假期试图寻找奎宁的合成版本，奎宁是治疗疟疾的药物。当时，疟疾、寒热病在欧洲非常普遍。人们认为能够生产合成奎宁对任何能发现它的人来说都将是一笔巨大的财富。
So that's what he was doing. He was spending his days working on this in his father's attic. And on one of his failed experiments, what he ended up with in his test tube was a sort of purple sludge. And I think, you know, he definitely knew this wasn't quinine, but I think possibly because he was interested in art and had painted in his younger days. He decided that rather than just throwing this purple sludge away, he would add a bit of really colourfast and very vibrant purple die. And this was incredible. In fact, it led to a whole revolution in synthetic dies. It was the first synthetic die that could be manufactured, not using any natural components, so no bugs, no vessels, no porcelain fish, and it just allowed purple to be worn by a much greater section of society than ever before. And so the invention of MOVE really just impacted the entire textile industry because of this
所以这就是他正在做的事情。他每天都在父亲的阁楼里研究这个。在他的一次失败实验中，他在试管里得到的是一种紫色污泥。我想，你知道，他肯定知道这不是奎宁，但我认为可能是因为他对艺术感兴趣，年轻时画过画。他决定与其把这种紫色污泥扔掉，不如加一点……这是一种非常耐洗且充满活力的紫色染料。这太不可思议了。事实上，它引发了合成染料的整场革命。它是第一种可以制造出来的合成染料，不使用任何天然成分，所以没有虫子，没有贝类，没有……它只是让紫色能够被比以往任何时候都大得多的社会阶层所穿着。所以苯胺紫的发明确实影响了整个纺织工业，因为这种
possibility, so it opened up an artificial dye, and is that the right way to put it? Yes, although you'd think it would be kind of immediate, you'd think that the whole world would very quickly cotton on, if you'd excuse the pun, to the value of this synthetic dye. But in fact, it took a while for this scientist who was called William Perkin to persuade textile dyers that this was the way forward, because they were used to working with natural plant a'r i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyrwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllwyr i'n pwyllw He persuaded a couple of textile mills to use this dye,
可能性，它开创了一种人造染料，这是正确的说法吗？是的，尽管你会认为这会是即时的，你会认为全世界会很快明白这种合成染料的价值。但事实上，这位名叫威廉·珀金（William Perkin）的科学家花了一段时间才说服纺织染工这是前进的方向，因为他们习惯于使用天然植物……他最终说服了几家纺织厂使用这种染料，
and one of them ended up selling a gown to some members of royalty. So Princess Eugenie wore a gown in this purple, and then the real clincher was Queen Victoria, wore a mauve gown to one of her daughter's weddings, and this got sort of greatly reported in the press that was this new color, and it became a complete fashion trend,
其中一家最终把一件礼服卖给了皇室成员。所以尤金妮皇后穿了一件这种紫色的礼服，然后真正的决定性因素是维多利亚女王，她在她女儿的婚礼上穿了一件苯胺紫色的礼服，这在媒体上得到了广泛报道，这是一种新颜色，它成为了一种完全的时尚潮流，
so much so that a year after Queen Victoria had worn this gown, a sort of satirical, English newspaper reported that London had become afflicted with the move measles because so many people were wearing this color. Ha, ha, ha, ha. I think I was intrigued, especially by the color green afflicted with the move measles because so many people were wearing this color. I think I was intrigued especially by the color green in your book because it seems like it is this thing that's so fundamental to nature, it's everywhere, but it was historically really challenging to make. Could you explain why that is? Yeah, so although, like you say, we kind of look around the world and it seems like there's
以至于在维多利亚女王穿这件礼服一年后，一家讽刺性的英国报纸报道说，伦敦患上了“苯胺紫麻疹”，因为太多人穿着这种颜色。哈哈哈哈。我想我对你书中的绿色特别感兴趣，因为它似乎是自然界中如此根本的东西，它无处不在，但在历史上制造它却非常具有挑战性。你能解释一下为什么吗？是的，所以虽然，就像你说的，我们环顾世界，似乎有
a lot of green in our world. In fact, it's very difficult to make stable, vibrant green colourants, either as pigments in paint, but also in dyes as well. And there were some who were sort of adept at it, and very often artists who were able to make vibrant greens would make them by layering various different colours on top of each other. And dyes would have to sort of again work with several different dye colours, which was, you know, in the medieval world,
很多绿色在我们的世界里。事实上，制造稳定、鲜艳的绿色着色剂非常困难，无论是作为油漆中的颜料，还是在染料中。有些人对此很精通，而且通常能够制造出鲜艳绿色的艺术家会通过在彼此之上叠加各种不同的颜色来制造它们。染料也必须再次使用几种不同的染料颜色，这在，你知道，中世纪世界，
the mixing of dyes was really frowned on. Who, why is that? It's often because of guild restrictions, because they were very protective of their guild skills. And so a dyes guild that dealt with woeed or indigo, blue dyes, were very reluctant to also work with yellow colorants. And so the mixing of blue and yellow to create a green was almost seen as as devilish and really transgressive in many ways. That's amazing.
混合染料是非常不被赞成的。谁，为什么会这样？这通常是因为行会限制，因为他们非常保护他们的行会技能。所以处理菘蓝或靛蓝（蓝色染料）的染料行会非常不愿意同时也使用黄色着色剂。所以混合蓝色和黄色来创造绿色几乎被视为邪恶的，在许多方面是非常越界的。太神奇了。
Because it's like something that any kid with paint knows how to do almost instinctively. Yeah, it is an odd one. It's one of those things where you suddenly realize how far away you are from the people you're studying when you're reading these documents and you're looking at these debates surrounding it and prosecutions. The prosecution of people making green cloth. Right. So artists were able to find good reds and good yellows, but greens were kind of hard to find. How did they end up finding the right green for painting? kind of hard to find. How did they end up finding the right green for painting?
因为它就像任何玩颜料的孩子几乎本能地知道怎么做的事情。是的，这很奇怪。这是一种当你阅读这些文件并看到围绕它的辩论和起诉时，你会突然意识到你离你正在研究的人有多远的事情。起诉那些制造绿色布料的人。没错。所以艺术家们能够找到好的红色和好的黄色，但绿色却很难找到。他们最终是如何找到适合绘画的绿色呢？
Yeah, so greens were elusive. Some artists were able to create vibrant greens by using kind of intermediary layers, and it was a real kind of trade skill. It was a closely guarded secret by some artists, you know, the secret to their green, their ability to create these beautiful colors. secret to their degree and their ability to create these, you know, beautiful colors. But there aren't really very many stable, natural, green pigments that artists have access to, which meant that when they started being created in this kind of, you know, rush of new chemicals and experimentation in the 19th century, the creation of new greens, they were taken up really rapidly and without much thought or care for what she was contained in these greens. In particular, a green called Sheila's Green, could you tell us about the uptake of that and the horrible effects of that?
是的，所以绿色很难捉摸。一些艺术家能够通过使用某种中间层来创造鲜艳的绿色，这是一种真正的贸易技能。这是某些艺术家严守的秘密，你知道，他们绿色的秘密，他们创造这些美丽颜色的能力。但艺术家们真正能接触到的稳定、天然的绿色颜料并不多，这意味着当它们在19世纪这种新化学品和实验的浪潮中开始被创造出来时，新绿色的创造被非常迅速地采用，而没有太多考虑或关心这些绿色中含有什么。特别是，一种叫做“舍勒绿”（Scheele's Green）的绿色，你能告诉我们关于它的采用和可怕的影响吗？
Yeah, so this was created by a Swedish scientist in 1775. And because there was this dearth of bright green pigments on the market, and this was relatively cheap, it got taken up by artists and wallpaper manufacturers and dress makers incredibly quickly. Well within a decade it was kind of everywhere. One of my favorite stories is that the writer Charles Dickens came back from a trip to Naples where he'd seen a lot of this green being used and decided that he was going to decorate his entire house, this one particular shade of green, from the basement to the attic.
是的，所以这是由一位瑞典科学家在1775年创造的。因为市场上缺乏明亮的绿色颜料，而且这相对便宜，它被艺术家、壁纸制造商和服装制造商非常迅速地采用。在十年内，它几乎无处不在。我最喜欢的故事之一是作家查尔斯·狄更斯从那不勒斯旅行回来，在那里他看到了很多这种绿色被使用，并决定他要装饰他的整个房子，这种特定的绿色，从地下室到阁楼。
And very luckily for him and for us, who have read and enjoyed his work, his wife just dissuaded him and said that she thought it was disgusting color. And he ended up not decorating his entire house, this particular sort of grassy emerald green. And I say luckily for us because it was discovered that this pigment that was made from arsenic was really poisonous or could be really poisonous. It was found that in samples of wallpaper that were, you know, only a few inches across,
非常幸运的是，对于他和我们这些读过并欣赏他作品的人来说，他的妻子劝阻了他，说她认为这是一种令人作呕的颜色。他最终没有用这种特定的草绿色装饰他的整个房子。我说这对我们很幸运，因为人们发现这种由砷制成的颜料确实有毒，或者可能非常有毒。人们发现，在只有几英寸宽的壁纸样本中，
contained enough arsenic to kill two adults. One of the industries that this green was really popular in was the artificial flower industry, because obviously it was used to paint the stems and the leaves of these artificial flowers. And a girl called Matilda, who was quite young, I think she was only 18 or 19, started working in an artificial flower factory and very quickly became very ill. And a doctor in London started looking into the causes of this because you know, she had a really disparate array of symptoms and eventually discovered that it was this green colourant but by that time it was far too late it was all over the country, all over the world, it was used in wallpaper and dress fabric, you know, you name it, it
含有足以杀死两个成年人的砷。这种绿色非常流行的行业之一是人造花行业，因为显然它被用来涂这些人造花的茎和叶。一个叫玛蒂尔达的女孩，她很年轻，我想她只有18或19岁，开始在一家人造花工厂工作，很快就病得很重。伦敦的一位医生开始调查其原因，因为你知道，她有一系列非常不同的症状，最终发现是这种绿色着色剂，但到那时已经太晚了，它遍布全国，遍布世界，它被用于壁纸和服装面料，你知道，你能想到的，它
was painted this, you know, arsenic, laden, green. But one of the most famous supposed victims of this green is actually Napoleon. It was found out after his death that there was quite a lot of green in the wallpaper that was used to decorate his rooms. And it was thought for a long time that this arsenic green might have contributed to his death. Although subsequent tests have actually shown,
被涂成了这种充满砷的绿色。但这种绿色最著名的所谓受害者之一实际上是拿破仑。在他死后发现，用来装饰他房间的壁纸中有很多绿色。很长一段时间以来，人们认为这种砷绿可能导致了他的死亡。尽管随后的测试实际上表明，
they managed to find samples of samples of his hair throughout his life. Goodness only knows how, but they tested all these samples of hair and found that actually he had really high arsenic levels throughout his life and that it didn't rise suspiciously just before his death. Although I'm sure being in a room covered with arsenic wallpaper, can't have helped his health one little bit. One of the strange things I think you learn reading your book is the place of blue in history. How popular was blue as a color throughout history? So now it's one of the most popular, if not the most popular, color globally among men and women.
他们设法找到了他一生中头发的样本。天知道是怎么找到的，但他们测试了所有这些头发样本，发现实际上他一生中砷含量都很高，而且并没有在死前出现可疑的升高。尽管我敢肯定，待在一个覆盖着砷壁纸的房间里，对他的健康一点帮助都没有。我认为你在书中了解到的奇怪事情之一是蓝色在历史上的地位。蓝色作为一种颜色在历史上有多受欢迎？所以现在它是全球男性和女性中最受欢迎的颜色之一，如果不是最受欢迎的话。
And it's kind of seen as being, you know, inspiring trust and confidence and all good things. And you kind of, you're tempted to kind of push that back into history. But in fact, if you look at the ancient world and kind of really up until the 14th century, Blue was seen as unlucky, uncouth, unfashionable, associated with kind of barbarism, particularly in the West, this is, in Western thought and Western culture. And it was only with the kind of the rise of the cult of the Virgin Mary in Christianity because she was popularly depicted wearing blue garments that blue began to have this cultural resurgence in Western thought and suddenly became pretty quickly a really popular color.
它被视为，你知道，激发信任和信心以及所有美好的事物。你倾向于把这种感觉推回到历史上。但事实上，如果你看看古代世界，一直到14世纪，蓝色在西方思想和西方文化中被视为不吉利、粗俗、不时髦，与某种野蛮联系在一起。直到基督教中圣母玛利亚崇拜的兴起，因为她被普遍描绘成穿着蓝色服装，蓝色才开始在西方思想中出现这种文化复兴，并很快成为一种非常受欢迎的颜色。
That's amazing. So who decided to depict her wearing blue? I mean, who made that decision to change the world? Yeah, so it's kind of incredible. So I'm around about the same time that the cult of the Virgin Mary was growing. The use of this particular pigment, um, ultramarine, which was made from lapis lazilai, was growing and being kind of perfected. Pislazili was growing and being kind of perfected. And again, because it was this really vivid color and was incredibly expensive, it became a way of artists and patrons
太神奇了。那么是谁决定描绘她穿蓝色的呢？我的意思是，是谁做出了改变世界的决定？是的，这真是太不可思议了。所以，大约在圣母玛利亚崇拜兴起的同时，这种特定颜料——群青（ultramarine）的使用，它是用青金石制成的，正在增长并被某种程度上完善。青金石正在增长并被某种程度上完善。而且再次，因为它是一种非常鲜艳的颜色且极其昂贵，它成为了艺术家和赞助人
of showing their devotion to the Virgin Mary by depicting her in this really expensive luminous pigment that came from a very long way away. You know, even its name, ultra marine comes from ultra and marae beyond the sea. The pigment itself kind of has this amazingly exotic connotations and that became bound up with the cult of the Virgin Mary and the two kind of bounced off each other and brought each other up in a funny sort of way. Could you describe how Ultramarine was made?
通过描绘她使用这种来自非常遥远地方的极其昂贵、发光的颜料，来展示他们对圣母玛利亚的虔诚的一种方式。你知道，甚至它的名字，群青（ultra marine）来自“ultra”和“mare”，意为“海外”。颜料本身带有一种惊人的异国情调，这与圣母玛利亚的崇拜结合在一起，两者相互促进，以一种有趣的方式提升了彼此。你能描述一下群青是如何制造的吗？
Sure. So many people are familiar with Lapis Lazuli, which is the semi-pressure stone is the kind of the raw material for making Ultramarine. It's kind of a really gorgeous dark blue stone that's used a lot in jewelry and kind of looks a little bit like the night sky It's this really deep blue and it often has kind of trace series of white that look a little bit like clouds
当然。所以许多人熟悉青金石，它是制造群青的原材料，这是一种半宝石。它是一种非常华丽的深蓝色石头，在珠宝中被大量使用，看起来有点像夜空。它是这种非常深邃的蓝色，通常带有少量的白色痕迹，看起来有点像云朵，
and also Can often contain little pieces of fool's gold that look a little bit like stars. It's really beautiful But in order to get from this very gorgeous Semi-precious stone to a pigment takes an awful lot of hard work. The minds, the Afghanistan minds where the LAPIS and Lazy I came from were incredibly remote. The stone would have to be loaded onto donkeys and camels, taken across the silk route to the coast of the Mediterranean, put on ships, and they would usually fetch up in Venice, which is sort of the the ports where so many luxury goods came into Europe.
而且通常可以包含看起来有点像星星的小块“愚人金”。它真的很美。但为了从这种非常华丽的半宝石变成颜料，需要大量的艰苦工作。阿富汗的矿山，也就是青金石的来源地，极其偏远。石头必须装上驴子和骆驼，穿过丝绸之路到达地中海沿岸，装上船，它们通常会到达威尼斯，这是许多奢侈品进入欧洲的港口。
And once an artist had bought his piece of Lapis Lazuli, the work was still far from over. The stone had to be ground down to a powder and then it had to be purified. Those bits of fool's gold and the white traceries that I mentioned in the original stone had those elements had to be removed because they turned the blue colorant rather dull and a bit ashy. And the way that was done is the blue, the powdered blue stone would be mixed with a mastic wax and then it would be needed, almost like you're sort of needing a dough to make bread in a solution of of lye. And as the dough was was needed and the flakes of blue would fall out to the bottom of the lye solution and you'd then be able to tip a'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
一旦艺术家买到了青金石，工作还远未结束。石头必须被研磨成粉末，然后进行提纯。我之前提到的原石中那些愚人金的碎屑和白色纹理，必须被去除，因为它们会让蓝色颜料变得暗淡且有些灰暗。处理的方法是将研磨后的蓝色石粉与乳香蜡混合，然后像揉面团一样在碱液中揉捏。随着面团的揉捏，蓝色的薄片会落入碱液底部，然后你就可以...
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
（重复内容）
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio' pigments that was used during this time and very often when you see a painting of the Virgin Mary she'll be swathed in a rich blue cloth and usually that cloth will be painted using ultramarine. And it's also kind of at the root of one of my favourite kind of colour facts, which is that you know, although now we think of pink as being for girls and blue as being for boys. In fact, if you were to go back sort of a, you know, just a little over a century, a century and a half,
（重复内容）当时使用的颜料，通常当你看到圣母玛利亚的画作时，她总是身披华丽的蓝色长袍，而那件长袍通常是用群青颜料绘制的。这也触及了我最喜欢的一个关于颜色的事实的根源，那就是，虽然现在我们认为粉色是给女孩的，蓝色是给男孩的，但实际上，如果你回到一个多世纪、一个半世纪前，
it was the other way around pink and was sort of seen as pale red and was much more associated with boys and blue because of association with the Virgin Mary was seen as the more feminine and dainty color. Mm-hmm, well. The process of extracting and purifying these colors seems so arduous and speaks to the desire for the end product
情况恰恰相反。粉色被视为浅红色，更多地与男孩联系在一起；而蓝色因为与圣母玛利亚的关联，被视为更女性化、更娇柔的颜色。嗯，确实。提取和提纯这些颜色的过程看起来如此艰辛，这说明了人们对最终产品的渴望，
that they would go through such efforts to try to create it. You've identified this like real human pursuit of like, basically, you know, food, shelter, and the brightest color imaginable. It seemed to be just part of ingrained in our DNA. Yeah, we love shiny bright colors and we are prepared to do all sorts of weird and wonderful things to have them. So I want to talk about orange because I need to know once and for all what came first,
以至于他们愿意付出如此巨大的努力去创造它。你指出了这种真正的人类追求，基本上就是食物、住所，以及你能想象到的最明亮的颜色。这似乎已经融入了我们的基因。是的，我们热爱闪亮明亮的颜色，并且准备好为了拥有它们而做出各种奇怪而美妙的事情。所以我想谈谈橙色，因为我需要彻底弄清楚到底是先有颜色还是先有水果。
the colour or the fruit. The fruit came first. Yeah, well there you go. Yeah, the fruit came first and as it travelled across the world, it brought its name and its colour with it, which is rather nice, but, in the English language, orange was called orange. It was actually called yellow red, which kind of makes sense, but isn't... Yeah.
是先有水果。是的，就是这样。是的，先有水果，随着它在世界各地的传播，它带来了它的名字和颜色，这很不错。但在英语中，橙色并不叫橙色。它实际上被称为“黄红色”，这在某种程度上是有道理的，但并不是……是的。
It's a bit long-winded. So let's talk broadly about the colour black. I think people think of black as one thing, but there are lots of different shades of black. So could you describe what black is and what black means in the world? Yes, it's a funny thing that if you go into a paint shop or clothing store, you can find so many hundreds, thousands of variants of white and we can call them cream or ivory or pearl and we've got lots of different names for them. And yet we just sort of collapse
这有点冗长。那么让我们广泛地谈谈黑色。我认为人们认为黑色就是一种颜色，但实际上黑色有很多不同的色调。那么你能描述一下什么是黑色，以及黑色在世界上意味着什么吗？是的，这很有趣，如果你走进一家油漆店或服装店，你可以找到成百上千种白色的变体，我们可以称它们为奶油色、象牙色或珍珠色，我们有很多不同的名字来称呼它们。然而，我们却把
so many subtle blacks into one very big overarching label. And in fact black has many different subtleties of tone, you know, as white does. And yet we just don't, you know, our vocabulary for black is really poor. And that, you know, was one of the colours that I was most worried about when I was writing the book. I was like, oh, you know, am I going to get to this one chapter and just have nothing to say. And I found completely the opposite. I found I became frustrated. I wanted people of the past to have been as excited about black as they were about reds and blues because it seemed to me that there was such richness there that it seemed a shame that we, you know, I didn't have the vocabulary to do it justice.
这么多微妙的黑色归纳为一个非常大的笼统标签。事实上，黑色和白色一样，也有许多细微的色调差别。然而我们就是没有……我们对黑色的词汇量真的很匮乏。这确实是我在写书时最担心的颜色之一。我当时想，哦，我会不会写到这一章时却无话可说。但我发现完全相反。我感到很沮丧。我希望过去的人们能像对待红色和蓝色那样对黑色感到兴奋，因为在我看来，黑色中蕴含着如此丰富的内涵，我们没有词汇来公正地评价它，这真是一种遗憾。
Well, so when you talked earlier about the arrival of MOVE or the arrival of green into the world and how the world just kind of exploded with excitement and how amazing it is to think of discovering or seeing a color for the first time, the closest analog I can come to is when I saw Vanta Black for the first time, which almost breaks your brain without Black it is. Can you describe what Vanta Black is and how you encountered it? Yeah, so I guess you should probably start with the name Vanta Black. It sounds sort of very space age, but actually it's kind of, it comes from a useful acronym, the Vanta stands for vertically aligned nano tube array. And essentially,
那么，当你之前谈到“MOVE”或绿色的出现，以及世界如何因兴奋而爆发，以及想到第一次发现或看到一种颜色是多么神奇时，我能想到的最接近的类比就是我第一次看到“Vanta Black”（梵塔黑）的时候，它几乎让我的大脑短路，因为它太黑了。你能描述一下什么是梵塔黑以及你是如何接触到它的吗？是的，我想你应该从“Vanta Black”这个名字开始。它听起来非常有太空时代的感觉，但实际上它来自一个有用的缩写，Vanta代表“垂直排列的纳米管阵列”。本质上，
Vanta Black is, it's not really a colour, it's more of a substance that absorbs more light than anything else on Earth. And that is because of its structure, because of these vertically aligned tubes, tiny, tiny, tiny filaments of carbon fiber. The light gets kind of absorbed between and amongst these fibers and can't get out, it gets trapped. And so very little light is reflected. What did they make this substance? Well, it was created for kind of a really specific purpose. Mae'n gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r
梵塔黑并不是一种颜色，它更像是一种吸收了地球上比任何其他物质都多的光的物质。这是因为它的结构，因为这些垂直排列的管子，即微小的碳纤维细丝。光线在这些纤维之间被吸收，无法逃逸，被困住了。因此，反射的光线极少。他们为什么要制造这种物质？嗯，它是为了一个非常具体的目的而创造的。（重复内容）
gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweithio'r gweith And so there's been this kind of creation of super blacks, you know, by NASA and various other people who work with satellites or will make satellites. But a British company sort of out of nowhere discovered a much blacker black than had ever been discovered before. You know, it only reflects about 0.065% of the visible spectrum. So, you know, it really is uncannily black.
（重复内容）因此，NASA以及其他从事卫星工作或制造卫星的人创造了这种“超级黑”。但是一家英国公司不知从哪里发现了一种比以往任何时候都更黑的黑色。你知道，它只反射了可见光谱中约0.065%的光。所以，它确实黑得不可思议。
And it's far too dark, it's far too light absorbing for it to give our eyes any information about the kind of environment we're in. So what I mean by that is when I first saw a sample of anter black, it was kind of grown onto a sample of, onto a piece of crumpled up aluminum foil. And when you looked at the reverse, you could see all the different planes, you could see that it was a scrumpled piece of aluminum foil from the different planes of light. And that gave you
它太黑了，吸收了太多的光，以至于无法给我们的眼睛提供关于我们所处环境的任何信息。我的意思是，当我第一次看到梵塔黑的样本时，它是生长在一块揉皱的铝箔纸上的。当你观察背面时，你可以看到所有不同的平面，你可以通过光线的不同平面看出这是一块揉皱的铝箔纸。
information about where you were in relation to the tin foil and the fact that it was scrumpled and all the rest of it. When it was turned over to expose the van to black coated side, suddenly what you saw was what looked like a kind of a mistake, like an acumen black hole, because your eyes weren't being given enough information. So what you saw was, even though you knew that this piece of aluminum foil was 3D, you
这为你提供了关于你与锡纸的关系以及它被揉皱的事实等信息。当它被翻过来露出涂有梵塔黑的一面时，突然间你看到的是看起来像是一个错误的东西，就像一个黑洞，因为你的眼睛没有得到足够的信息。所以你看到的是，即使你知道这块铝箔纸是3D的，
know, had lots of contours, you couldn't discern that all of a sudden, all of a sudden all you could see was just a black hole and that was incredibly uncanny, both for me, sort of, yeah, completely mad, seeing it in a sample, in a lab, even though I knew exactly what I was going there to see, I went there expecting it and yet still I couldn't quite wrap my head around it, but it really shocked people and I spoke to the scientist who was involved in its creation. And he said he was getting calls from people soon after it had been discovered, telling him that this creation must in some way be associated with
你知道它有很多轮廓，但你突然无法辨别了，突然间你所能看到的只是一个黑洞，这令人难以置信地诡异。对我来说，在实验室里看到样本时，即使我完全知道我要去看什么，我带着预期去，但仍然无法理解它，这确实让人们感到震惊。我采访了参与其创造的科学家。他说在它被发现后不久，他就接到了人们的电话，告诉他这种创造一定在某种程度上与
the devil because, you know, anything that black that gave back that little information to our eyes must be, you know, intrinsically evil, which is such an odd, you know, an odd knee-jerk reaction. But in fact, you know, it's incredible. Yeah, but it's also, it totally harkens back to all these stories that you've told us, that these associations, these primal associations, we have with these colors, it sounds exactly like, you know, the alchemists told that they can't mix blue and yellow, or they're going to work at the devil. Yeah, maybe we haven't moved on all that far after all.
魔鬼有关，因为任何如此之黑、给我们的眼睛提供如此少信息的颜色一定本质上是邪恶的，这是一种多么奇怪的条件反射。但事实上，这太不可思议了。是的，但这完全回到了你告诉我们的所有故事，即我们与这些颜色之间存在的原始联想。这听起来就像炼金术士说他们不能混合蓝色和黄色，否则他们就是在为魔鬼工作。是的，也许我们毕竟没有走得太远。
Maybe not. I actually had a question about the design of the book itself. Yeah, maybe we haven't moved on all that far after all. Maybe not. I actually had a question about the design of the book itself. It's really beautiful. And one of the coolest parts is that you have a colored stripe on the edge of the pages that go with each color story. But I couldn't help but think about how stressful it must have been. You know, you have to be right on the money that you got the right pigment
也许没有。我实际上有一个关于这本书本身设计的问题。是的，也许我们毕竟没有走得太远。也许没有。我实际上有一个关于这本书本身设计的问题。它真的很漂亮。最酷的部分之一是你在页面边缘有一条彩色条纹，与每个颜色的故事相对应。但我忍不住想到这一定压力很大。你知道，你必须确保你得到的颜料是准确的，
in the printing process and everything, that there's something that kept you up at night. Yes, it did. I'm not gonna tell you which color it is that gives me, that still gives me sleepless nights. But I have it, I had anxiety nightmares about people coming at me and saying, you're your sky blue is wrong
在印刷过程中等等，有什么事情让你彻夜难眠吗？是的，确实有。我不会告诉你到底是哪种颜色让我至今仍彻夜难眠。但我确实有，我做过焦虑的噩梦，梦见人们冲向我说：“你的天蓝色错了”
or whatever it is, I just thought, oh no, I thought I'm going to get myself into so much trouble. And what was so stupid is that part of the argument of the book is that there is no true ultramarine. Colors are cultural creations and they're kind of shifting all the time, sort of like tectonic plates. Color is not a precise thing. It's changing, it's living, it's constantly being redefined and argued over. And that's part of the magic of it. That's part of why I love it, but it's also part of why
或者类似的话，我只是想，哦不，我想我会给自己惹上大麻烦。最愚蠢的是，这本书的部分论点是根本没有真正的群青。颜色是文化的创造，它们一直在变化，就像构造板块一样。颜色不是精确的东西。它在变化，它是活的，它不断地被重新定义和争论。这就是它魔力的一部分。这就是我喜欢它的原因，但这也是为什么
it is infuriating. And particularly when you find yourself in the position of having to choose the right color for each and every page of your book, you end up finding the whole thing completely ridiculous and cursing the fact that you were interested in colour in the first place. A final story from Katia Zinclair about the colour blue in art forgery, and Nazis. When we come back.
它令人抓狂的原因。特别是当你发现自己必须为书中的每一页选择正确的颜色时，你最终会觉得整件事完全荒谬，并诅咒自己当初对颜色感兴趣。来自Katia Zinclair关于艺术造假和纳粹中蓝色颜色的最后一个故事。我们回来后继续。
With one of the most amazing stories of art forgery, here again is Cautier Saint Claire. Just after the Second World War, a lot of people in Europe were being prosecuted for collaboration and those who'd collaborated with the Nazis during the war were being investigated. And one of those was an art dealer called Van Migren, who had sold an awful lot of canvases of Vermeer's and various other artists, to Nazi collectors and even to kind of hit his own art collection itself.
带着最令人惊叹的艺术造假故事之一，再次请出Cautier Saint Claire。第二次世界大战刚结束时，欧洲有许多人因通敌而受到起诉，那些在战争期间与纳粹合作的人正在接受调查。其中之一是一位名叫Van Migren的艺术品经销商，他向纳粹收藏家出售了大量维米尔和其他艺术家的画作，甚至包括他自己的艺术收藏。
The prosecution sort of began of this art dealer. And he turned around and said, actually, you shouldn't be prosecuting me. You should think of me as a hero because far from selling out amazing Dutch-owned art to the Nazis, what I was actually doing is I was creating these masterpieces from scratch, I'm a forger, I was never selling for me as to the Nazis,
对这位艺术品经销商的起诉开始了。他转过身说，实际上，你们不应该起诉我。你们应该把我当作英雄，因为我远没有把荷兰珍贵的艺术品卖给纳粹，我实际上是从零开始创作这些杰作的，我是一个伪造者，我从来没有把维米尔的画卖给纳粹，
I was just ripping them off. And he had made a fortune during this period. He'd made, I think, the modern figure is somewhere in the region of around $33 million that he'd made by selling these supposed artworks. So he found himself in this really odd position of having to prove that he was guilty of forgery in order to prove that he was innocent of collaboration. And the pigment that eventually kind of proved that he had forged these pictures, which by this time were in all those, that had most well respected art galleries all over Europe,
我只是在骗他们。他在这一时期赚了一大笔钱。我想现代数据大约是3300万美元，这是他通过出售这些所谓的艺术品赚到的。所以他发现自己处于一个非常奇怪的境地，必须证明自己犯有伪造罪，以证明自己没有通敌。最终证明他伪造了这些画作的颜料，而这些画作当时已经出现在欧洲所有最受尊敬的艺术画廊中，
he'd fooled an awful lot of people as well as the Nazis. But the pigment that this all turned on was cobalt blue because it had been discovered a long time after Vermeer's death and yet was discovered to have been used in this one particular Vermeer, fake Vermeer that he had created. And so he managed to prove that he was guilty of forgery because of the presence of Cobalt Blue, where in fact he had meant to use ultramarine, which was, you know, the pigment that Vermeer would have used. That's so good. Well, this is so much fun. Thank you so much. I enjoy this immensely. Oh, it was my pleasure. It was really great fun. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, music by Sean Rial.
他欺骗了很多人，也欺骗了纳粹。但这一切的关键颜料是钴蓝，因为它是在维米尔死后很久才被发现的，但却被发现用在了这一幅特定的维米尔伪作中。因此，他因为钴蓝的存在而成功证明了自己犯有伪造罪，而实际上他本打算使用群青，那是维米尔会使用的颜料。太棒了。好吧，这太有趣了。非常感谢。我非常享受。哦，这是我的荣幸。这真的很有趣。99% Invisible本周由Emmett Fitzgerald制作，音乐由Sean Rial创作。
Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffleman, Terran Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Sharif Yusif, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
Katie Mingle是高级制作人，Kurt Colstead是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑Delaney Hall、Avery Trouffleman、Terran Mazza、Joe Rosenberg、Vivian Lee、Sharif Yusif、Sophia Klatsker以及我Roman Mars。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。99% Invisible是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个极其独立的集体，
of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you can probably surmise the show's favorite color at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汇集了播客界最具创新性的节目。请在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，或关注节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但你可能已经猜到了该节目最喜欢的颜色，就在99PI.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。